[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai écouté ça toute la journée j'ai
écouté ça et j'ai coûté bien cher
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aller ailleurs
ah ah
[Musique]
si ce mal comment ils emploient un
bouffon
[Musique]
est ce que vous faites les sécher quand
il ya le gars on oriane et non bien une
fête d'entreprise et gioria tôt et qu'il
offre
il ya le gars de la compta carrera les
jo
[Musique]
la zone
c'est malheureux
[Applaudissements]
à
des problèmes digestifs voulais dire à
toute l'équipe
en ce moment je sache et que jean moulin
j'en ai dit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai sonné
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]